welcome back your insurance agency the
sponsors of this segment are back with
care more Health to discuss what you
should be looking for when considering a
primary care provider
welcome back to your insurance agency
our special guest today is Dr wadwin
with care more which is the medical
director officer for care more one of
the things we wanted to talk to you
about today is in the sea of many
choices what makes your provider Network
different and so I welcome Dr wad Rudd
to share with us what's unique about
care more so caramel health is an
advanced Primary Care Group we're a
group of clinicians that are in your
neighborhoods providing life-changing
care to our Las Vegas residents
especially those with chronic and
complex conditions you know we at care
more believe in whole person care often
taking care of patients involves not
only addressing their medical needs but
also their social and emotional needs
our Healthy Start or of new patient
appointments are designed just for that
they're about 60 Minutes long and it
allows your provider to have enough time
to get to know you do a comprehensive
head to toe assessment we can then
identify your medical needs as well as a
social and emotional needs and then we
can partner with our patients to develop
personalized care plants to address the
issues that are most important to them
with many complex issues that we have to
serve our clients that ultimately become
your patients it's a very difficult job
to sometimes do so what services do you
provide that really set you apart from
the other medical groups absolutely
the right place at the right time our
patients all have access to care more
anytime this is a special number in
which they can call a clinician and have
access to a collision clinician 24 7 365
days a year in cases of an emergency we
also provide same-day access and walk-in
appointments for all of our patients at
any of our three locations across the
valley in addition if it's you're unable
to get to us we have a team of mobile
providers that can come to your house
and assess your condition and then
provide your and address your concerns
we also provide virtual access to our
patients so at care mall we want to meet
our patients when and where they need
care I truly believe it takes a village
to take care of patients so with our
Advanced Primary Care model our patients
have access not only to the primary care
physician but also an interdisciplinary
team which includes chronic disease
practitioners social workers case
managers community health workers
sub-specialty support such as Behavioral
Health clinical pharmacists Podiatry
this allows us to provide whole person
care that we believe is so important for
our patients one of the things that
makes care more uniquely different is
the care model
if you notice I didn't mention doctors
because doctors may come and go but the
value of care or the care model Still
Remains the Same care more does retain
doctors too but sometimes they do come
and go and that's important to know that
you have a care model that's going to be
there for you to take care of you for
long-term needs we appreciate our
partnership with care more it's nice to
have something behind us Brokers that is
there to help support the people we
serve best we have well-trained Brokers
ready to serve you to help you find a
good care more location and doctor to
work with
thank you to your insurance agency for
sponsoring this segment you can find
them at the Galleria and Meadows Malls
that you can call the care more call
line at
702-487-8869 or visit
yianv.com care more for more information
Las Vegas now we'll be right back